tic le premier sujet de l'actualité
aujourd'hui c'est d'abord donc la visite
du président de la république ce matin
au salon de l'aéronautique et de
l'industrie spatiale au bourget une
visite attendue est importante quand on
connaît les options je dirais
moralisatrice que monsieur françois
mitterrand veut apporter en matière de
vente d'armement georges leclercq a
suivi sept visibles ni précis on se
demandait dans les milieux de l'aviation
si le président de la république allait
ou non inaugurait ce 34e salon du
bourget qui reste quand même un des
hauts lieux du commerce mondial des
armes ce matin l'atterrissage de cet
hélicoptère puma de l'aérospatiale le va
tous les doutes
françois mitterrand s'intéresse aux
avions mais l'elysée avait fait savoir
que le président ne souhaitait pas
rendre visite aux engins de guerre
la présentation aura donc un caractère
essentiellement civils et avec le
président de la république quelques
ministres ont fait le déplacement du
salon du bourget
charles hernu pour la défense
jean-pierre chevènement pour la
recherche et la technologie pierre joxe
pour l'industrie michel jobert pour le
commerce extérieur
la couleur est donc afficher la france
continuera à être une nation de pointe
en aviation en espace mais aussi et cela
ces sous-entendus en armement les avions
présenté en vol vont d'ailleurs refléter
cet état d'esprit il y a quand même près
de 300000 emplois en jeu et des
élections la semaine prochaine première
démonstration les hélicoptères civils de
l'aérospatiale avec un très beau vol du
dauphin que vous voyez ici
avec ces engins l'aérospatiale accède au
tout premier rang mondial en rivalité
avec les états unis
c'est encore en rivalité avec les états
unis que l'airbus va effectuer ici son
vol de démonstration extrêmement
spectaculaire avec un arraché du sol
évidemment l'airbus et vite c'est plus
facile
l'airbus dont la version le petit cousin
la version a320 a été annoncé hier par
le président d'airbus industrie là aussi
c'est un formidable marché qui se dégage
de rivalité franco américaine
les organisateurs du salon n'ont pas
hésité il faut quand même faire voler un
chasseur de l'armée française c'est le
mirage 2000 le voici
mais ce mirage 2000 ne porte aucun
armement aucune bombe aucune roquette
aux commandes le pilote d'essais de chez
dassault mito maurouard qui comme
d'habitude bien sûr fait très belle
démonstration lesbiens
au sol le présent la république
s'intéresse à l'espal voici les deux
cosmonautes français qui viennent
d'arriver d'union soviétique où ils
s'entraînent ils voleront probablement
en 1982 avec un sayoud soviétique
bien sûr la fusée ariane a retenu toute
son attention puisque le décollage est
prévu le 19 juin c'est à dire à la fin
de ce mois mais on attendait la visite
du stand d'assaut nationalise abl le
président de république à regarder les
avions en dessous
pas d'armes elles ont toutes été
déménagées pendant la nuit peut-être
forte de l'elysée
et enfin pour terminer le spectacle a
liés à l'aviation
la patrouille de france dans une
démonstration éblouissante avec du
panache